it's Thursday and that means it's time
for Thursday
Folly and for that we turn to Fox
contributor Raymond aroyo all right
Raymond didn't you have a happy birthday
wasn't that fun um but you know I
invited him he didn't show up Sean Penn
because he was very busy recently in
this week with the whole zalinski visit
to the United States and he went on Jake
Tapper on CNN to push his new zalinski
documentary yeah yeah this is an amazing
piece of propaganda Laura but what
stopped me in my tracks is when Penn
with a straight face argues President
Biden and America aren't helping Ukraine
enough understand the frustration I have
a lot of respect for President Biden but
I think that anybody in the decisive
position right now is really failing the
aspiration of America no more smoking
mirrors about how long it takes to train
all of those things were myths the
reality of it is by now they could have
had the f-16s long in the air and it
would have saved a lot of lives already
lost does he not realize the
consequences of sending those f-16s I
mean we are sending Fighters into battle
we've dropped 113 billion dollars in
Ukraine since this started with little
accountability I might add so we're not
sending our Fighters not that we know to
I mean I mean the Jets but the fighter
jets but what's interesting about Shawn
Penn is that he's obviously a very
talented filmmaker and he's he's done
some amazing films I'd like to send him
down to the Border Raymond because he
seems to be very concerned about borders
and people not having their aspirations
fulfilled perhaps we might turn our
sides to America next because there
happens to be a lot of discontent in
this nation well and sininsky has
brilliantly used Shawn pen to push the
message out and then sha pren brings in
the Oscar so he can get another round
Raymond we should do a documentary of
Sean pen doing the documentary on that's
a good one all right Raymond because
it's Thursday yes Roll Tide by the way
sorry um I'm granting you three Thursday
wishes oh my goodness you're so kind my
first wish is that people would stop
pushing these alleged aliens as if they
were real this week some Mexican doctors
claimed that those two mini aliens
presented to the Mexican Congress were
nonhuman NASA says don't bet on it I'm
not convinced either they could be
totally human in fact we did our own
digging in our own Congress and look we
found a couple of potential specimens
Laura they're old aliens but that
doesn't make them nonhuman oh my
goodness obviously we're having some
extraterrestrial fun but that's alarming
actually there like a little casket
that's an insult to the mommy all right
my second wish is what oh second wish
I'll tell you it's two-tiered you'll
like this I really wish President Biden
could get help aid and assistance when
entering the stage without assaulting a
foreign flag the president of the United
States and the president of the
federative Republic of Brazil
accompanied by the director general of
the international labor
organization that's that's the Brazilian
flag he almost knocked over which brings
me to my second wish lore when the
president meets with world leaders I
wish he would engage them with real
diplomacy can promise you that we will
do our very best not to deceive you Mr
[Applause]
President he just he walks away
president Lula D Silva Brazil by the way
he looked he looked over to go to shake
hands and he went he brushed him off and
ran off the stage I don't blame him if
this is the world coming together the
United States is back I hate to see
America when it's gone well there was a
moment today with sininsky where it
seems like there was also a hesitation
about what to do next and there was
thankfully a person there to help right
at the White House yes all right Raymond
what is your final wish on this final
wish jeie artist Jin's haning was hired
by a Dutch Museum in 20121 to create a
piece about wage differences in the
European Union the museum even sent him
actual money to incorporate into the
work well when he delivered it the
finished product it looked like
this empty canvases it turns out hanik
changed the title of his work to take
the money and run and then he did I wish
museums would stop commissioning idiotic
works like this that no one wants to see
Laura the the court and Copenhagen by
the way said he had to repay them
$70,000 for the money I thought that was
actually people were ooh I like what
that that shade of white is so the
shadow on the canvas look when you
squint and get down you know get down a
little low it looks like he's actually
created a wage I mean this so don't you
love van go and Mones are you can Splash
Campbell Soup on them but these things
we're paying hundreds of thousands of
dollars for it's remarkable can I get
one more wish do we have an extra
emergency wish oh my goodness okay yes
it'll be fast it'll be fast I wish
someone would tell John fedman that it's
not Halloween here's the senator last
week with a Bob Casey mask during an
interview why is he walking around with
a picture of another
Senator he needs an intervention well
I'm just I'm not understanding that nor
am I understanding this the dress code
issue which maybe it was for zinsky for
his visit so feel at home is that why
they changed the Senate dress Cod maybe
it wasn't really about Federman so
zalinsky could show up with the um the
Dickies Dickies for everybody I mean
sell Dickies anymore yeah sure they yeah
people who work in the I remember those
were big and my father was a mechanic he
used in junior high like the kids who
didn't have the money like we had to
have the Dickies everyone else had the
cool pants like oh you're wearing
Dickies we better go they're going to
give me another wish well okay well
Raymond have a good rest of your week
weekend hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else